(orchestral music)
- Yeah, there's no room for fear
in this world of mine.
Forget that.
Has been a bit of a road.
I first saw wingwalking
when I was kinda in my early twenties.
I was bumping around and I didn't want
to go to college.
I didn't know what I wanted to do in life.
Saw an advert for my local airshow
and saw a nanosecond of a wingwalker go by
in a Javelin and that was it.
I was owned.
I decided right then and there that
that was going to be the rest of my life.
It took me from that point seven years
of begging and pleading every
wingwalking team in North America,
to basically just even
get me up in the sky.
(orchestral music)
It's like being in a
category five hurricane
on a roller coaster from
hell with no way off.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] So why
do you keep doing it?
- [Carol] Because I'm a mad woman.
(laughs)
(orchestral music)
The airplane that you
see behind me right now,
in a weird twist of fate
that's actually the very first airplane
that I ever wingwalked on
and now it's my airplane.
My life just wouldn't be worth it
if I couldn't wake up in the morning
and go do this.
C'mon.
Doesn't it look like
the funnest thing ever?
That's the reason I get
out of bed in the morning.
That's what makes me smile.
That's what makes me not care
if I have to work 16 hours straight
for five days in a row if I get to go
and do this at the end of it.
Anytime that you can aspire
to see a human, another human being
kind of achieve their inner thing
and that when you can witness
triumph over adversity,
I mean it just kind of motivates you
to fuckin' be proud of your race.
It's like when you see those great videos
of dogs doing super cools things,
doesn't that just make you love dogs?
Same thing.
(laughs)
(orchestral music)